Good morning John, and thank you for your
video on Monday in which you treated us to
a glimpse of the magnificently complicated
world that defines the lives of small plants
that happen to produce fibrous strands of
cellulose that can be converted into things…
sock puppet: Like me!
And that is mind-blowing, I mean, it’s cotton-
and you didn’t even scratch the surface
of how complicated the actual global cotton
industry is! The number of people, things,
and complexities necessary to turn, you know,
like sunlight, air, and soil into a shirt?
You don’t even wanna know!
It reminds me of something else you said to
me recently, you said ‘Hank, it all comes
down to the fact that the truth resist simplicity.’
And you’re always saying marvelous things
like that, and it’s always very frustrating,
because, for me to come up with marvelous
things like that I have to be like, typing
for hours and hours and hours and I’d be
like, oh, that’s a good, that’s one good
thing that I came up with. But that’s why
you’re the professional writer and I'm the
professional…goofball. I feel like I need
to do something now to prove that I'm the
professional goofball, maybe I'll just- *slaps
self* Ooowwww!
Anyway, I just love that, the truth resists
simplicity, I love it especially because,
It’s a simple truth talking about how rare
simple truths are. Is there a word for that?
It feels like there should be a word for that.
I'm not a writer! Nerdfighters, comments,
tell me if there’s a word for that.
We like to think that the most complicated
things that we’re ever gonna learn are the
hard sciences like math and physics and chemistry,
but really, those are the simple things. Cause
at least there’s definite answers. At least
at the level you’re learning about in high
school, now that I think about it, chemistry
and physics, and math, there’s a lotta stuff
that’s not definite.
But what’s even more complicated than that
is like, history! When your history teacher
gives you a test, there’s a question that
says ‘What were the implications of the
Magna Carta?’ Nobody freakin’ knows the
answer to that question! Maybe without the
Magna Carta we’d all be Nazis. Maybe we’d
all be dead! Maybe we’d be fighting an evil
race of genetically engineered space monsters!
Maybe we’d all be drinking pig’s milk
for breakfast! Sock puppet: Probably not.
What?
Sock Puppet: There’s good reasons why we
don’t drink pig’s milk.
W-like-really? Like what?
Sock puppet: Well, it’s complicated.
Oh, of course it’s complicated, what’s
so complicated about it?
Sock puppet: Well it has to do with a lot
of different stuff, like the reproductive
system of the pigs, and the practice of breeding
pigs generally for meat and not for dairy-
Even the reason we don’t drink pigs milk
is complicated! Wow, Hank sock, I had no idea
that you were such a specialist on pig…milking…practices.
Sock puppet: Well, there’s a lot of stuff
you don’t know about me.
We love simplicity, and we want simple stories.
Like, we want there to be a homeless man with
a golden voice that was never recognized for
his talent until the internet found him, when
in actuality it’s a story of a man who went
to school and worked hard to develop his voice
then made a thousand bad decisions that led
to him becoming homeless, not because no one
recognized his talent, but because he was
addicted to alcohol and drugs.
We want the untainted love of Edward and Bella
to be both perfect and immortal, and it can
be, because it’s fake! We want simple solutions!
This intelligent looking Asian man for example
thinks that maybe they can power the entire
amusement park with a hybrid drive! Even though
that would violate the third law of thermodynamics!
Which apparently people at Toyota’s advertising
don’t know about, uh, it’s the one where
you can’t create energy from nothing!
And we wanna make simple assumptions about
the tragedy in Tucson. We want to fit it into
our simplistic worldview, where we can blame
the people we’re already blaming, when really,
it’s just a breakdown in the most complicated
system, probably in the known universe, the
human brain. And that same system, so thoroughly
damaged somehow, still functioning in congresswoman
Giffords, proving once again that the truth.
Resists. Simplicity.
I think one of the principal facets of being
a mature and healthy and effective person
is understanding…that you are almost always
wrong. And you might not be all the way wrong,
but at least…a little bit. You’re always
a little bit wrong. We, as a species, don’t
know the answer to the vast majority of questions.
And it turns out that one of the hardest parts
of all this, and possibly the most important
part, is accepting, that we don’t have those
answers. And that our simple little explanations,
are flawed. Sometimes dangerously flawed,
especially when we start talking about political
news analysis.
Thanks John, for making me think about all
that stuff, I'm gonna go play Lego Harry Potter
now, because at least there, I know the difference
between good and evil, John I'll see you on
Friday.